I'm not going to pronounce your name
Josh avanza comma mama kuru said any
advances in the field of interstellar
travel as we have discovered seven new
exoplanets
yeah so he want you what you want to
leave her what he wanted rather like I
gotta get out of here now
I heard Goldilocks zone and I'm like I'm
ready to go well so the problem is the
fastest spaceship we've ever launched
the fastest thing if you aimed it for
the closest exoplanet and get the other
seven right go to Proximus injury
it's called Proxima so my B is closed
right because this is why this we gave
gift gave it that name it's four
light-years away well because the other
one is what is it 40 50 light-years I
forgot the number but it's tens of light
you to Proxima Centuri right there I aim
your fastest thing we have ever launched
take you 70 thousand years let's go
tomorrow
so you got to figure out how to defy
your biology right or invent a wormhole
and I'm going to I'm gonna bet on the
wormhole okay not cryostasis now and
then make a movie and a cup and we wake
up seventy thousand years later okay and
you know of course it's the thing you
only have a five o'clock shadow some
reason in the movies go to sleep for
70,000 at we go I might need that's not
the only issue in the movie they never
pee or poop and move exactly X right
there other issues there are other
gallon any great if you like this please
remember everything that we do can be
found commercial-free plus exclusive
original content all on Startalk all
access calm